there's a company in japan  that's been dumping their toxic waste  into the sea  the people need help we need global  attention  we need you i'm the greatest  photographer that life magazine has ever  had  that you are you're the single most  impossible photographer that life has  ever had  listen to me i need the pictures genie  bring the story home  the cover-up is going to be as much of a  story as the story itself  you cannot let your emotions run the  show  why would i be  the native americans they believed that  a photograph would  literally take a piece of the subject's  song  but they can also take a piece of the  photographer's soul  [Music]  focus on the photograph you want to take  focus on what you want to say  you